telephonic interviews mark the beginning
journey of your interview process
it is a crucial decision maker as it is
a filtering round there are chances of
you losing your dream job because of an
unrehearsed telephonic interview
currently with the ongoing pandemic
audio and video interviews have become
the need of the hour
hence it is important to be prepared for
a telephonic interview at a moment's
notice
this video on the top seven telephonic
interview tips will acquaint you with
the do's and don'ts while giving a
telephonic interview you can use these
tips to ace your next telephonic
interview
these tips can also be applied to your
video interviews
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell icon to never miss an update
from simplylearn
before diving into the tips let's
recognize what role a telephonic
interview plays in the hiring process
employers use telephone interviews to
identify the right candidate for a
particular job role
recruiters call candidates who have
impressive resume to understand if they
are the right fit for the job
telephonic interviews make the screening
process easier by shortlisting a handful
of applicants from an entire pool of
applicants for the in-person interviews
having a telephone call or a video call
makes it relatively quick to determine
whether a candidate is suitable or not
for a remote position a telephonic
interview may be the only way
sometimes telephonic interviews are also
held because of other geographical
barriers or situations like the current
pandemic
hence it is advised that you are
prepared for a phone or video interview
at any given time if your telephonic
interview goes well
congratulations you will move on to the
next stage of the interview otherwise
things are unlikely to progress
telephonic interviews usually last for
30 to 45 minutes or even less you have a
short time to positively impact the
recruiter and convince him or her that
you are the right fit for the job so
here are a few tips to help you crack
your next phone interview
our first tip to you is to understand
the job description well and research
about the company ideally you would have
done this while applying for the job
however it is good to brush up on that
knowledge before your telephonic
interview
suppose you know the name of your
interviewer beforehand in that case it
will be great to search him or her on
the internet to understand the
interviewer well
next choose a good spot to give the
interview in most cases you will be
informed of the date and time of your
interview well beforehand
use this to your advantage and choose a
room where you can speak without any
disruptions
make sure you don't witness any tv
traffic or any other noise
additionally keep your family members
aware of your interview so that there is
no disturbance from their end as well
after choosing your ideal spot make sure
that you use a good phone with good
connectivity or preferably the landline
for your telephonic interview
at no point should there be any call
drops or poor network coverage at this
time
sometimes virtual interviews take place
over various other platforms like zoom
hangouts etc
at such times make sure to have a strong
internet connection and get familiar
with the platform before the interview
while giving your interview make sure
that you're not eating or drinking
yes you can have a glass of water kept a
sip if your mouth gets dry while talking
our third tip to you is to keep a hard
copy of your resume ready before you
this will help you recollect what you
have on your resume as a reference
usually interviewers would keep looking
through your resume while taking virtual
interviews
hence make sure that you have one before
you do have a well-prepared resume and
remember your resume would be the factor
that will decide if you get a phone
interview or not in the first place you
can also keep a pen and paper handy to
take down notes during the interview if
required
next telephonic interviews also allow
you to show that you are a good listener
too you don't have to keep ranting
interrupt and dominate the conversation
instead let the recruiter guide the
conversation
listen carefully and answer the
questions asked you don't need to talk a
lot to impress the interviewer at any
point if you have any questions you can
jot them down and save them for the end
make sure to wait and think before you
start answering a question
once the interviewer asks you a question
give a second or two and then answer
also by doing so you both won't end up
talking all at once which will sound
chaotic and can be awkward
our fifth tip to you is on how to answer
your questions
make sure to be thoughtful and concise
with your answers
as we mentioned before you have only a
short time to impress the interviewer
with your answers
so prepare your answers well beforehand
you can watch our video on top 10
interview questions and answers to ace
this section
while answering your questions in a
telephonic interview the tone matters a
lot
you must display enthusiasm in your
voice it is advised that you smile while
answering yes it may seem odd as nobody
will see you smile but if you smile it
will bring a positive tone to your voice
and you will seem to be more energetic
and enthusiastic
make sure you don't speak like a robot
in a monotonous way and seem
disinterested
focusing well on telephonic interviews
can get tougher on the phone than in
person
hence do not get distracted and stay
alert display good communication skills
and language skills to move ahead in the
interview
our sixth tip to you is to dress well
for the interview dress as you would for
your face-to-face interview this way you
will develop more seriousness in you and
you will not take telephonic interviews
lightly keep in mind that this is still
an elimination process and hence there
should be no scope for negligence if you
are going to give a video interview then
make sure you are very careful about
your dressing and come across as
professional to the interviewer
along with dressing well your body
language also matters in both audio and
video interviews it is but natural if
you don't sit up straight and take the
interview you might slowly seem
lethargic
hence make sure to sit up straight and
take the interview as you would for a
face-to-face one
our last tip to you is on how to
conclude the interview
when the interview is over you can ask
the questions you have jotted down
during the interview after which make
sure to say thank you in some cases it
is also advised that you send a short
thank you note to the interviewer a day
after the interview and provide any
information that you didn't get a chance
to mention during the phone interview
in most cases there will be a follow-up
from the recruiter's side so give them
some time to get back to you with the
result
so those were our top 7 tips to help you
ace your next phone interview spending a
lot of time talking on the phone needn't
help you master a telephonic interview
hence carry out a mock telephonic
interview and incorporate the tips we
discussed this way you will be
stress-free during your real telephonic
interview
as they say
practice makes a man perfect remember to
give telephonic interviews the same
importance as you would for a
face-to-face interview what are your
tips for a telephonic interview
let us know in the comment section below
and the best tip stands a chance to win
amazon voucher
that brings us to the end of this video
on telephonic interview tips we hope
these tips are helpful to all you job
seekers out there and i wish you all the
very best thank you for watching the
video and stay tuned for more from
simply learn
[Music]